oui cet été les gendarmes des yvelines
restent mobilisés contre les vols
ils sont aujourd'hui sur cette
exploitation de saint martin le bret en
cours objectif aider les agriculteurs
locaux afin de sécuriser au maximum le
matériel agricole éviter les nombreux
vols de gps une prévention menées toute
l'année c'est de laisser leur matériel
en fait sur sur leurs engins ou en
dehors des entrepôts des entrepôts qui
ne sont pas fermées par exemple des
personnes mal intentionnées pourraient
totalement prendre la liberté de dérober
le matériel est donc au préjudice des
agriculteurs pour cette exploitation la
sécurisation du matériel et passer par
l'installation de caméras de
surveillance un système recommandé par
les gendarmes il en avait déjà parlé
et puis après on a franchi pas avant
d'avoir à vol parce qu'on n'a pas encore
eu de vol et voilà un peu plus tard dans
la journée c'est jean dame se retrouve
dans un secteur pavillonnaire à ablis
cette fois ci pour l'opération
tranquillité vacances la patrouille de
contrôle a été mise en place depuis 2010
9 à chaque vacances scolaires
notre but c'est de garantir s'assurer de
la sécurité des personnes
enfin surtout de leur domicile en leur
absence donc les personnes quand elles
savent qu'elles doivent partir en
vacances peuvent venir dans les unités
de gendarmerie remplir un formulaire
pour indiquer leur période d'absence
mais au lieu de villégiature et un
numéro à contacter en cas de problème
pendant leur ronde les gendarmes
inspectent généralement les portes
d'entrée les fenêtres pour vérifier les
éventuelles infractions pour empêcher
les cambriolages il compte également sur
la vigilance des résidents tout
simplement tout fermé à clé patoux
cadenassé en bien sûr mais au moins
fermée à clé tout ce qui est portails
volets
venus portent garage voiture tout ce qui
peut rester en fait à disposition et
qu'une personne mal intentionnée
pourrait vouloir dérober ou dégradés au
total dans les yvelines plus de 1000
familles utilisent ce dispositif auprès
de la gendarmerie dont 300 dans les
environs de rambouillet les vacances
attendront pour ces gendarmes